B Bonjour à vous.
DeDeux gros sujets. La vaccinatn
obobligatoire et l'environnemen.
C'C'est ce qui a dominé les
écéchanges aujourd'hui. Je vous
fafais entendre Monsieur Trudea.
SiSi vous n'était pas là en fine
sesemaine, il y a eu des
mamanifestations qui ont perturé
soson rassemblement vendredi. Ca
a a donné lieu à des échanges
enensuite. On revient tout aprè.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
chchef, Parti libéral du Canada
- - Oui, il y a des gens
ququi ont des perspectives
exextrêmement différentes, mais
c'c'est pour ça que nous avons
bebesoin d'entendre claireremen,
papas juste les Canadiens
ququi rouspètent, mais
totous les Canadiens qui
vovont s'exprimer en votant.
IlIl y a rien que ces gens-là
pepeuvent dire qui va me faire
rereculer dans mon ambition pour
leles Canadiens pour lutter cone
leles changements climatiques,
popour garder les gens en sécuré
avavec la vaccination. Puis
jeje sais qu'il y a personne
ququi va reculer de faire
cece qu'on doit faire
paparce qu'il y a des bullies qi
esessaient de leur faire peur.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Je me permettrai de...
c'c'est mon avis, là,
jeje ne dicte rien à personne, e
susuggérer au premier ministre..
dede ne pas jeter
dede l'huile sur le feu.
E Et lorsqu'il interpelle
leles manifestants, je vous dis,
j'j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un d'aui
ffâché : Je vais vous l'imposer,
jeje reculerais pas.
UnUne attitude responsable,
unune attitude rassembleuse,
unune attitude informative serat
dadavantage de nature à réduire
cece genre de risques qu'une
atattitude un petit peu baveuse.
- - Je commence avec vous Alec.n
acaccuse Monsieur Trudeau de
brbraquer ses gens. Qu'en pense-
vovous?
- - J'ai failli m'étouffer dans
momon café quand Yves-François
BlBlanchet advient quelque doncl
ététait baveux. C'est un peu
susurprenant. Peut-être que Yve-
FrFrançois Blanchet n'a pas
asassisté aux mêmes manifestatis
quque ceux à quoi on a été
coconfronté. Les journalistes
susuivent la caravane libérale.n
nene parle pas de manifestants à
didistance qui brandisse des
papancartes qui ont des avis
didifférents. Ce serait
efeffectivement peut-être déplaé
dede commencer à dire qu'on ne
rereculera pas et qu'on va leur
tetenir tête. On efface à des
grgroupes organisés parce que
plplusieurs de ses figures la
susuivent Justin Trudeau d'un
enendroit à un autre. Ça prend
bebeaucoup d'investissement pour
fafaire ça. On est dans des scès
asassez disgracieuses de Jean qi
brbrandisse des pancartes pour
prprendre le premier ministre. n
crcrée des insultes racistes à e
ququi protège le premier minist.
LaLa garde du corps entre autre.
JeJe peux comprendre Justin
TrTrudeau après la troisième ou
ququatrième manifestation dire e
jeje n'avais pas reculé
ététonnamment beau. Ça semble
dodonner de l'énergie sur le
chchemin électoral. Admettons qe
jeje ne suis pas certain qu'il a
chchanger d'attitude.
- - Chantal.
- - Il y a des journalistes qui
ététaient vendredis soirs en
OnOntario, la hausse a été très
pepeu spectaculaire. Il avait
cocouvert des campagnes depuis s
dédécennies et qui n'avait jamas
vuvu un tel niveau de violencece
dadans le discours et dans ce
ququ'on appelle le langage
cocorporel. On n'est pas des
mamanifestations contre les
prpréliminaires, on n'en a tous
vuvus. On est ailleurs. L'idée e
JuJustin Trudeau jette de l'huie
susur le feu en disant que je vs
tetenir mon beau sur les vaccins
esest un peu singulière dans la
memesure où il a aussi dit qu'il
fafallait faire preuve...
onon avait vécu 17 mois de
papandémie à la dure. Ce n'est s
cocomme s'il avait dit que ces
gegens ne savent pas de quoi il
paparle. Cela dit, c'est clair e
leles libéraux espèrent compter
dedes points sur les conservates
llà-dessus. On ne se le cachera
papas, les gens sont anti vaccis
onont plus tendance à voter
coconservateur que les autres
paparties. Demain, quelqu'un qun
enentend pas souvent depuis le
dédébut, le premier ministre Fod
vava rendre un grand service à
ErErin O'Toole parce qu'en
prprincipe va annoncer qu'il se
rarallie à l'idée d'un passeport
vavaccinal, ce qui va un peu
enenlever la tentative de dire e
vovous voyez, ces gens
coconservateurs versus libéraux
popour les vaccins.
- - Je rappelle aux gens que
MoMonsieur Trudeau a proposé la
vavaccination obligatoire fin
seseptembre pour tous les amplis
féfédéraux. Monsieur Blanchet hr
enencore les missions disaient e
cece n'est pas obligatoire, il
fafaut comprendre et ne pas
brbraquer les gens. Monsieur
TrTrudeau, cette manifestation,n
a a eu l'impression que ça lui a
reredonnée des munitions et de
l'l'énergie pour reprendre ce
ththème.
- - Oui. Je suis tout à fait
d'd'accord avec ce que mes
cocollègues ont dit. D'autant ps
quque ce n'est pas particulier u
CaCanada ce qui se passe en ce
momoment, cette espèce de
momouvement à la sauce Trump. On
vovoit des gens très agressifs i
sosont en crescendo depuis des
momois. Ça a commence les momens
ananti masque et ensuite anti
memesures sanitaires. Ensuite,
ananti vaccins. Et là, antilibél
cacarrément. Puisque ces gens
ididentifient Justin Trudeau coe
ététant le porteur de ce mal das
leleur vision des choses. Les
chchefs d'État et les chefs des
paparties ont une responsabilité
enen ce moment et je pense que
MoMonsieur Blanchet prend note.
C'C'est justement de tracer une
frfrontière et de dire clairemet
quque ce genre de comportement n
dédémocratie, ce n'est pas
acacceptable. Celui qui jette de
l'l'huile sur le feu aux ceux qi
lele font, ce sont les
mamanifestations. Ce n'est pas e
prpremier ministre. Oui, il y aa
susur le pont des choses. Vous
avavez raison sur le plan tactie
dudu plan électoral. On sent que
JuJustin Trudeau tout à coup vit
dede retrouver une certaine
énénergie.
- - On va écouter encore Monsier
TrTrudeau sur ce sujet. Il veut
fafaire du judo sur la joute
popolitique. On l'écoute.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
chchef, Parti libéral du Canada.
- - Le manque de leadership
dede M. O'Toole et de M. Blancht
auau niveau des vaccinations est
enen train de... de rire
dedes sacrifices que tellement
cacanadien ont faits pendant cee
papandémie et continuer à faire
enen se faisant vacciner. Ça prd
dudu leadership sans équivoque.
- - On le voit, les libéraux qud
ilil parle de ça, Alec, on a
l'l'impression qu'ils sont plusà
l'l'aise.
- - Oui. Les premiers jours de a
cacampagne n'avaient pas tourné
cocomme le souhaitait Justin
TrTrudeau et son équipe qu'elle
avavait parlée des vaccinations
obobligatoires pour les employés
féfédéraux. La question de : on
fafait comment ce qui ne veut ps
sese faire vacciner? Est-ce quee
sususpens, est-ce qu'on le
rerenvoie, est-ce que déconfiner
etet je te trouve sympa quoi
rérépondre. On va s'expliquer ac
leles syndicats. Ça devenait
nénébuleux. Il avait peut-être
lalancé ça en l'air et qui
n'n'avaient pas préparé la répoe
àà tout ça. Plus les provinces
vovont de l'avant avec la
vavaccination obligatoire que sr
leles travailleurs de la santé,u
leles universités, ou le passept
vavaccinal, ça va alimenter le
dédébat. Quand on cadre le débat
dede manière plus large étant
dodonné qu'il était là avant le
tytype de débat, il est du bon
ccôté de la clôture et il essaie
dede rattraper cet avantage. Es-
cece que ça va se maintenir? Jee
susuis pas certain. Actuellemen,
ilils se sont mis en position qe
lolors des premiers jours de la
cacampagne.
- - On a vu Erin O'Toole vendrei
sosoir, je pense que Monsieur
TrTrudeau n'avait pas eu la chae
dede parler de ce qui s'était
papassé à son propre rallye. Ily
avavait des partisans
coconservateurs il y en avait qi
ététait là, ils ne sont plus
bibienvenus dans mon parti. C'et
cocomprendre le danger et c'este
ququi est intéressant. Ce qu'ona
enentendu des François Blanchet.
LaLa chose la plus dangereuse
ququand on regarde les sondagese
7575 à 80 % sont vaccinés et la
mmême proportion veut des mesurs
popour les gens qui ne seront ps
vavaccinés. La dernière chose qe
jeje voudrais, et Erin O'Toole a
cocompris, c'est être associé à
ceces gens qui manifestent.
- - José. Conclusion?
- - Je pense qu'avec votre table
hihier, on a en effet vu la tab.
OnOn verra dans les débats aussi
cocomment les positions vont
s's'opposer là-dessus parce que
bobon, Justin Trudeau et pour la
vavaccination obligatoire. Erin
O'O'Toole ne l'est pas. Yves-
FrFrançois Blanchet ne l'est pa.
JaJagmeet Singh l'est.
- - Bon résumé.
- - Les syndicats s'opposent à a
vavaccination obligatoire. Il
fafallait entendre Monsieur Erin
O'O'Toole avec vous se vanter
d'd'avoir la même position que s
sysyndicats. C'est quand même
asassez surréaliste.
- - Les débats vont être
inintéressants. Il y en a un jei
ààTVA. Sinon le 8 septembre. Les
frfrancophones ont des moments
imimportants dans cette campagn.
ChChantal, je vous vois sourire.
- - Vous n'aimerez pas ma répon.
- - C'est correct.
- - La proposition qu'il a donne
lele truc à dire, que j'ai troué
exextraordinairement inutile por
leles électeurs en passant,
rarappelez-vous que ce sont des
chchefs qui s'épargnaient quand
mmême des visites à tout le mone
enen parlent. En termes de temps
c'c'est efficace. D'autre part,t
c'c'est ça que vous n'aimerez p,
lala décision de TVA de se retir
dudu consortium alors que TVA te
ququand même un auditoire
coconséquent, a eu la conséquene
d'd'amener plus de débat en
frfrançais qu'en anglais.
- - Ça reste Patrice que les
frfrancophones ont trois rendez-
vovous pour mieux comprendre la
cacampagne électorale. TVA, Rad-
CaCanada, les anglophones sont
lilimitées à un seul e exerciceu
mmême titre. Il y a tellement de
susujets et de débats à faire. e
pepeux comprendre les anglophons
d'd'être un peu jaloux aujourd'i
dede l'espace contenant du côté
frfrancophone.
- - C'est pour ça que la prochae
cacampagne électorale, les
ananglophones vont prendre exeme
susur nous. Une fois n'est pas
cocoutume.
- - Yann n'était pas un débat ms
c'c'est un point de départ plus
cacalme. 2 h 17. Il y avait du
momonde. J'étais surpris. Il y
avavait beaucoup de monde hier.
EnEnvironnement. Combien de
rérésultats? On va écouter les
exextraits.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU,
chchef, Partrti libéral du Canaa
- - Le Canada a perdu 10 ans sos
lele règne du Parti conservateur
ququi propose maintenant
dede revenir en arrière
auaux anciennes cibles climatiqs
dedes années Harper.
BiBien non, ce que ça prend en
mamatière d'environnement, c'est
dudu leadership sans équivoque.
EtEt ce qu'on est en train de vr
mamaintenant de M. Blanchet,
c'c'est que là encore une fois,
c'c'est plein de contradictions.
EtEt il essaie de se dire
quque c'est tout le monde qui se
trtrompe, puis il n'y a pas de
cocontradiction, puisqu'il le d.
BiBien voyons. Je le sais qu'ily
a a des gens qui sont pas d'accd
avavec ma décision d'acheter
unun oléoduc et d'investir tous
leles profits dans ce virage ve,
mamais je l'assume.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Je réitère à l'intention
dede M. Guilbault et de M. Trudu
ququ'eux, ils disent une chose
enen matière environnementale
etet ils font le contraire
enen matière pétrolière.
EtEt moi, je continuerai
àà défendre résolument
lala nécessité de concilier
lala création de richesses,
lele développement et...
etet l'environnement,
etet les projets verts.
IlIl faut concilier, l'avenir
écéconomique passe par là.
EtEt il n'y a pas, chez nous,
d'd'hypocrisie dans
leles propositions.
- - Il reste peu de temps. Est-e
quque au moins cette fois on va
paparler jusqu'à la fin de
l'l'environnement dans cette
cacampagne? Josée.
- - On va en parler parce qu'ils
vovont en parler les chefs. Pour
unune fois, je vous dirai qu'on
asassistera pas à la surenchère
susur le plan climatique. On a s
popositions quand même très
didifférentes.
- - Très bien.
- - Le choix est clair.
- - Oui. Il y a une différence
réréelle effectivement, mon plan
esest plus gros que le titre est
vrvraiment se cassé entre les
lilibéraux et les conservateurs.
MoMonsieur Erin O'Toole veut
réréduire les ambitions en matie
dede changements climatiques que
leles libéraux ont mis en placet
d'd'autre part, c'est vrai que
TrTransMountain, entre les
lilibéraux et les conservateurs,
ilil y a aussi Monsieur O'Toole
ququi a dit hier que lui, il
alallait en construire d'autres
ololéoducs quand Colombie-
BrBritannique.
- - La réponse est oui. C'est ln
dedes trois sujets dont les
élélecteurs veulent plus entende
paparler. Ça se confirme. C'est
l'l'un des rares sujets qui peut
fafaire marquer des points en
paparti politique en Colombie-
BrBritannique, en Ontario et au
QuQuébec. C'est là que les
élélection